welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in guardians of the galaxy proved
that comic book movies can look like
comics and not apologize for characters
who just happen to be green or purple or
blue or trees or raccoons I'm sorry
trash pandas James Gunn's world-building
his humorous soundtrack ranked guardians
near the top of our Infinity Saga
rewatch series because each repeat
viewing reveals overlooked secrets
including one maddening mystery Easter
Egg that still remains hidden and we'll
talk about that bastard the film opens
with young Peter quill with a mixtape
given to him by his dying mother the
awesome mix Volume one and its sequel
vol 2 are the beating heart of these
films gun actually writes in the
tracklist into the scripts a rare move
since music licensee and isn't always
guaranteed and he recently tweeted how
he selected all the songs from
Meredith's point of view gun makes each
song diegetic playing from an audio
source in the scene really we are
listening in on an ongoing conversation
between a mother and her son this first
track is I'm not in love by 10cc about a
guy reluctant to tell a woman I love you
reflecting Peters reluctance to take his
mother's hand meredith is played by
laura haddock who also played a cap
fangirl dawn says there's no connection
between the characters meredith does
give a hint to volume to hear thank you
and he was Meredith's description of the
ego is pretty accurate sadly her brain
tumor was given to her by ego Peter gets
abducted and screams his core desire in
this film
plenty of discussion about Peters
lineage on his father's side but not
enough talk about his mom but I believe
Meredith quill is the secret to this
whole film on to Morag
Peter dances to read bones come and get
your love and ride heard this being his
mom's playlist the love he's after is
hers with a power stone bringing him
even closer to her something more
machine could never understand so he's
an idiot yeah Peter dances Pat's a
skeleton with a horse face similar to
the korbinites beta ray bill becomes
Thor in the comics actually made another
video recently about who this Skelton
could have been and how he could tie
into Thor war check it out
Peter's history scanner shows a girl
with a dog this is James Gunn's dog dr.
wesley von spears r.i.p hooch also
cameos in volume to Peter's face mask
admits from tech behind his ear it's
actually the same krei tech that carol
danvers uses in Captain Marvel Ashley
later in this movie Peter mentions a
tussle with a Kree girl right here at
Kree girl tried to rip out my thorax she
caught me with this skinny little ass
cam earring but I'm pretty sure it's
been confirmed that this was not Carol
Danvers now this Morag temple the
close-up on the orb way and me show up
to steal it and all evokes the opening
sequence of Raiders of the Lost Ark a
parallel that Brody actually alludes to
an end game with over woman this is the
part where you know spikes come out with
skeletons on the end of them and
everything what are you talking when you
break into a place called the Temple of
the Power Stone there's gonna be a bunch
of booby traps okay okay go ahead and
later in this movie Peter compares the
orb to famous movie MacGuffins like the
Lost Ark so this orb has a real shiny
blue suitcase Ark of the Covenant
Maltese Falcon sort of vibe Korath
arrives and his soldiers are sick Oren's
meaning they are from the trash planet
that later shows at the door Ragnarok
Peter escapes in a ship called the
Milano after Peters childhood crash
Alyssa Milano in his hookup beruete is
wearing these same summer camps shirt
that Peter was abducted in Peter's tape
deck includes a troll doll the same one
he trolls yondu with at the end there
are also some Alf stickers in this cat
eating alien life-form actually appears
in the Infinity Gauntlet comics and then
rate before yondu calls in you can see
Peter swiping through photos of other
females on what I seem to be a galaxy's
version of tinder yondu crag lin and the
other Ravagers where this patch now
that's actually the logo of the
guardians in the comics of all these
characters actually only gandu was an OG
Guardian in the comics
taller fin which was more accurate in
volume - and his yak I arrow in these
movies is adapted from his archery in
the comics he controls a via whistling
and his fin which lights up when he uses
it onto Ronan ship called the dark aster
now you may have noticed these
coordinates under each location as I
mention before James Gunn announced that
he hid an elaborate easter egg
throughout this film over the years
clever youtubers like Mt great guy have
gotten close by focusing on these
coordinates and now there is this
amazing a discord community all the
guardians egg basket where folks waste
smarter than I am have been able to
decode the phrase this is mom's cancer
this isn't real in the name Meredith
quill which when these geniuses have
tweeted this at James Gunn he has
responded with grades of 50 to 70%
correct they are so close and I highly
encourage you to help him crack it they
are definitely on to something with
Peter's mother her cancer and maybe her
connection to reality being the secret
to this film maybe the easter egg or
maybe this will end up being just a hot
take from a man-child seeking life
lessons from marvel movies we meet
thanasis adopted daughters Gamora and
nebula was to meet ronan a war hungry
zealot of the Kree Empire an empire
whose s Hillary has explored more in
Captain Marvel the ship was designed to
resemble a mausoleum when he crushes a
head
the blood trickles down into a place
where he sleeps meaning Ronan literally
sleeps in the blood of his enemies
that's why fantasies later threat to him
feels so personal return to me again
empty-handed babe the starways
on Tues and our home at the Nova Corps
hooded by Nova prime rocket and Groot
scan the locals for bounty including
Stanley the alien letters on a screen
translate to Stan's catchphrase of
excelsior but perhaps more interesting
there in the scroll language was this
really not they try to capture Peter
doesn't distinguish between genders
guess his race reproduces asexually they
get arrested and on all their booking
screens are hidden some fun Easter eggs
let's bring him down with the screen
down Mora is listed as the last survivor
the Z ho brave people a massacre that we
actually see in infinity ward's
suggesting that Thanos's crusade to save
populations by killing half of them
doesn't really work out too well it also
lists a bunch of cybernetic enhancements
and ocular and respiratory implants
rocket screen is very interesting it
lists his origin as half world rockets
origin in the comics world where
animal-like test subjects live it also
lists the name lilah who is Rockets
significant other in the comics now of
course there's definitely more to
Rockets backstory Gunn has stated that
volume 3 will explore the mystery of
which scientists engineered him many
over the years have speculated that
could be the High Evolutionary Herbert
Wyndham group screen identifies his
species the flora colossi from Planet X
now I actually go real deep into groups
of biological secrets and the next
episode of the big question be sure to
check that out Peter screen lists his
aliases spacelord since Roman day
refuses to call him star-lord oh sorry
his middle name its Jason as a nod to
Jason his father in the comics it also
lists one count of illegal manipulation
of agar motion Duchess promotions are an
obscure alien race in Marvel Comics
Peter also has a universal translator
implant which is a really clever piece
of world-building by James Gunn for them
to you so now whenever cosmic base
characters speak what we are hearing is
their translator implants at work just
kind of solves a lot of problems they're
taken to the kill in prison and their
prison garb is marked with these
barcodes for the number and type of
crimes that committed black for murder
other colors for arson burglary serious
bodily harm
the thicker the bar the more serious the
crime saga Juarez's asleep black BHT is
a killer some can
miios in this prison the monstrous alien
it's nathan fillion and the older inmate
who shouts is a cameo by Lloyd Kaufman a
filmmaker and mentor to gun Peter stops
tracks from killing Gamora by showing
him his scars you caught me with this
skinny little Oscar Marion who worked in
Nova records I was trying to get
information and we're seeing Oscar
Berrien tentacles needles for teeth
I think I'm seriously interested in that
you don't carry this gross mental image
is so scoring for Drax you can't help
but use it to identify Peter later and
we get our introduction of Josh Brolin
as Thanos and MCU this take on Thanos as
well as the origin story of the Infinity
stones was a task left to James Gunn by
Marvel Studios so really the biggest
step forward on the march to the
Infinity war was all thanks to this film
we had our first team of shot of the
guardians in the midst of their Prison
Break now my breakdown of the Avengers
talked about how it's really redemption
story but guardians of the galaxy is a
redemption story that's really true er
to the ragtag spirit of the Marvel
Comics Gunn described The Avengers as
the Beatles with the guardians of the
galaxy like the Rolling Stones whereas
the Avengers always have one foot set in
reality guardians of the galaxy doesn't
have feet in his tentacles and all 12 of
them are in different dimensions Peter
can't escape with them until he returns
for his mixtape again his connection to
Meredith is the key here the song here
is Rupert Holmes escape reflecting the
Guardians escape but also a song about a
missed connection and surprise
homecoming just like how Peter is trying
to make up for his missed connection
they plot their next move on the Milano
or if you want to blow up lose no one's
blowing up wounds later in infinity war
Thanos does end up using the power stone
to smash a moon into pieces they arrive
at nowhere which is inside the severed
head of a celestial in the comics the
Celestials actually killed by the
symbiote deity no using all black the
Necker sword
many of theorized that this giant skull
once contained the brain that later
became Peter's celestial father ego
Groot sprouts a flower gives it to a
young girl I know Maj do these seen in
the classic film Frankenstein luckily
Groot doesn't drown this girl in that
yellow spinal goop is where I thought
that was going peter shares his mom's
mixtape with Gamora explained to her the
plot of Footloose and how kevin bacon
save the day by dancing a joke that
comes back and infinity war told not to
dance off to sue viewers what dance-off
it's not a it's not a tie it's not I can
suppose to move exactly
photos is it still the greatest movie in
history it never was
I think about it Peters dancing as a
passion inherited from his mother her
music attracted ego and led to Peters
creation
Meredith legacies for her son to teach
the galaxy how to dance and notice the
setting here Peter and Gamora look like
they're in the eye of that celestial
skull if that theory is right and this
is ego skull kind of interesting to
think that it's like Peter's father
watching Meredith's legacy dance on
tracks and rocket drunkenly fight stupid
he does why did it have to get made I
didn't have to be torn apart and put
back together all over to some monster
another clue pointing to Rockets
mysterious surgical origin but also a
reflection of all the guardians here
each of them are broken toys packed with
implants their bodies considered
disposable until the Power Stone tears
their flesh apart it also brings it back
together
even poor splintered groups the
collector Taylor Devon returns to the
dark world post-credit scene his vault
is filled with Easter eggs
most of which by now you've probably
seen cosmo the telepathic russian dog
from the Guardians comics there's also a
dark elf from the dark world and a
Chitauri from the Avengers there's a
bunch of alien slugs from James Gunn's
horror film slither the organic looking
cocoon that was supposed to be the
cocoon of Adam warlock but Gunn later
retcon that with ayisha's golden cocoon
in the volume to post-credit scene if
you look closely you can also see Howard
the Duck already in the scene of course
we get a better look at him in the
post-credits scene where he's voiced by
Seth Green
what do you let him lick you like that
for gross
Howard returns in volume two and an
Avengers in game the Power Stone inside
the orb was actually originally gonna be
read as the power gem is in the comics
but Marvel Studios made them change it
halfway through production to purple
after they decided to make the red ether
in the dark world which is shooting
around the same time to be the reality
stone the collector alludes to Pat stone
wielders who disintegrated so those
losers must not have been as good of
friends as the guardians of improbably
I'd like a side of D&D group that he
cared about more we also see the
celestial Isan the searcher whom I've
theorized could have been Peters
grandfather egos father it sounds like
we will learn a lot more about these
ancient Marvel gods in the Eternals film
behind Peter is the close-up of this
wall art that was from the Morag temple
earlier it depicts ancient figures
forging these six Infinity stones and
the production designers identified
these as Death entropy eternity and
infinity death is of course based on
Lady Death in the Marvel Comics the
entity that represents all of death and
decay in the universe ruin her is Thanos
his motive in the Infinity Gauntlet
comics opposing death according to this
art is eternity and his sister infinity
in the comics eternity is another cosmic
entity who represents the full
embodiment of the multiverse itself to
pay for there's a giant silhouette
filled with stars and planets entropy is
eternity Sun locked in another dualistic
balanced eternity creates entropy pulls
apart now and volume two when ego opens
Peters eyes Peter says in that moment
his eyes reflect eternity starscape
appearance the more on this possible
secret connection later Corina snatches
stone destroys the vault
the exterior wide shot appears to show
the emblems of the six Avengers doors
hammer Mjolnir at the entrance a ring of
light that looks like Toni's arc reactor
a set of concentric discs that kind of
look like cap shield a radiation symbol
for Hulk a red glow beneath the spider
web pattern maybe for Black Widow and an
arrow shape amidst the purple glow for
Hawkeye seeing all these wipe down the
blast could suggest the Avengers coming
failure against Thanos with the stones
Ronan's forces arrived with the Ravagers
leading to a scramble you are just
sister I hated you least nebula is
hinted at the other children of Thanos
including the Black Order whom we meet
in infinity war
Peter rescues Gamora and gun said he
shot these scenes underwater to make the
hair float but it sucked because all the
bubbles kept getting in the way Peter
later explained colorful nebulas cloud
that surrounds nowhere is just super
interesting to me I've always wondered
if it could be the faults mentioned on
that dark world blackboard the fault is
a portal to the cancerverse from the
Guardians comics this imagery shows up
later in Peters vision of his mother who
was dying of cancer and these colors
were the backdrop to Peter and
gomorrah's moment earlier that youtuber
MTI talked about once theorized that
this backdrop could actually be eternity
sound alike Gunn denied it but I do
think there's something here with the
connection to Meredith quill I think
that's something that came over Peter
was the thought of Gamora as the woman
he shared his mom's music with the woman
whom meredith wanted him to take her
hand after ronan takes the power stone
for himself Peter forms a plan I have a
plan what percentage I don't know
12% 12% some saw that's 12% of the nod
to Tony and peppers 12% exchange and
Avengers give yourself 12 percent its
credit 12% an argument could be made for
15 but Gunn has explained that the
number 12 is often just using comedy
writing for pacing rocket is the last to
stand doing this little tuck that
someone suggested it's a nod to the
Picard maneuver maybe just Trekkies
cleaning all tuxes in homage to their
daddy in addition to playing crag Lin
James's brother Sean Gunn did the mocap
and onset dialogue for rocket in all
these movies and Rockets button here was
actually improvised by Sean Gunn we're
all standing up now but should jackasses
standing in a circle
it also shows Rockets dread that their
fates will be the same as the ancient
jackasses standing in a circle in the
battle the nova corps fleet forms a net
originally in the Nova fleet was
actually just gonna fold immediately as
they typically do in the comics and as
they did off-screen and infinity war the
sisters fight and I like how as nebula
straightens out her parts for hateful
eyes always remain locked on Gamora it
ends with nebula severing her own hand
to get away along with groots
severed arm earlier in the leg rocket
tricked Peter into getting this
continues pfeif he's weird fades to ode
to star wars amputations row that cliff
[Music]
who protects them from the crash
[Music]
this sacrifice inspires all of them to
lay down their lives like Adam warlock
Groot forms the cocoon that evolves all
these misfits into a team a team
officially named by Ronan here your
guardians of the galaxy
eaters things along the broken tape deck
whoo-chow
things are gonna get easier you champ
things are get brighter five Stairsteps
Oh Geoff is Meredith's latest message to
her child of strength through times of
turmoil
Peter grabs the stone and in this cosmic
chaos Gamora who moments earlier refused
Peters beckon now reaches out
[Music]
we refused his dying mother's hand and
his whole life since has been listening
to his mother to connect with others in
a dance to save the universe
and again Meredith's surroundings
reflect the colours around nowhere if
you think about it it was nowhere it's
coordinates that those clever discord
decoders translated to the name and
Meredith now Peter presumably could hold
the power stone because his father ego
was a celestial but again what about his
mother Nova prime IDs are as a Terran
and earthling but what if that was just
one form that she took I believe
Meredith quill herself could have been
one of the cosmic entities from that
Morag art watching down upon her son
eternity infinity maybe even lady death
Peter and Gamora fooled around fell in
love in the eye of ego as it gazed out
upon the surrounding eternity enshrining
how Peters parents fooled around and
fell in love to the same playlist in
volume to ego helps Peter see his mother
Peters dance with death in this moment
may be a literal one perhaps that this
isn't real translation that gun graded
correct could mean that Peters reality
is one set inside the confines of his
mother which is why her music continues
to guide him why egos brain tumor was an
eternity why'd cancer and why Peters
Saviour mentality spans all of existence
what does the galaxy ever done for you
why would you want to save it because
I'm one of the idiots who lives in it
look whether or not this meredith equals
space goddess take is legit her secret
message is the one that guards the
galaxy that misfits can redeem us all if
they can learn to dance together kragle
inand yondu even echo this down plain of
egos importance
yeah that guy was a jackass it ain't
always easy to keep these daily doses of
distraction coming at you from the blue
dungeon time it's imaginary here and
sometimes I see shapes and the shapes
become like friends the best way to wake
up from this delirium it's an energy
boost from bang energy thanks to bang
energy per sponsoring this video every
kind of bang is 16 ounces that's right
there's no wimpy 12 ounce cans here it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has zero calories yet
it tastes great with over twenty
different flavors to choose from one of
those grape flavors is a cotton candy
one sip of this very juice and your
whole life becomes a circus
check out bang on Instagram you can get
25% off your order at bang - energy calm
and use the code and new rock stars 25
there you can buy kids a bang energy
including their sweet tea Kato coffee
flavors and cotton candy gap you can
also get clothing fitness supplements
all kinds of stuff to be your best bang
so thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25% off at
bang - energy calm using code new rock
stars 25 and probably the inventor of
bang on istagram a bang energy dot CEO
and just like how rocket allowed Groot
to wipe away it's here earlier he now
lets Drax pet him which is crazy
normally he hates us and he does 10 stop
briefly but we see how he eases into
relaxation
zere's and the way his tail drops down
Peter opens Meredith's awesome mix vol 2
and her letter you are the light of my
life my precious son
my little star-lord another example of
Meredith's eternal influence Peter
stubbornness over star-lord is because
it was his mom's nickname for him a new
baby Groot sprouts and continues the
dance
Drax disapproves of old dancing Groot
stances actually performed by James Gunn
himself in mocap and if you watch all
the way to the end credits in the post
credits scene the credits also include
that's disclaimer no raccoons or tree
creatures were harmed in the making of
this picture really the closing image of
this film shows the guardians of the
galaxy in the repaired Milano all this
set - ain't no mountain high enough by
Marvin Gaye and Tammi Terrell the second
Marvel movie in a road to close out with
Marvin Gaye's vocals which of course
transitions into the Jackson 5's I want
you back Peter blasts off toward the
three sons of Xander the three stars
that actually inspired the Nova course
chest logo but also notice how that
distant star has a pinkish hue to it
maybe these stars reflect Peter and his
family the distant one being Meredith
alongside ego and star-lord and that
distant star is the star that these five
guardians led by their star-lord want to
get back to what do you think is James
Gunn's deeper secret of this movie James
good if you're watching this comment
down below and a reminder that you can
join our future watch Long's on new
rockstars discord server by becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash new rock
stars follow me on instagram and twitter
at EA vos following two rock stars and
subscribed in rock stars bruh our next
MCU breakdown when iron man somehow
survives cancellation after a rape joke
i will be reinstituting prima nocta Wow
[Music]